[Music]
[Music]
hey guys
Kos everything in the world trying to
stop me from doing this video you know
growing up as a child all I did was
watch cartoons reading comic books and
have fun and some of my favorite
cartoons are coming to life thanks to
Shai sideshow sideshow has put together
a super roster of childhood favorites
like I brought you Voltron and I will
bring you many others but today we're
gonna talk about one franchise yeah I
probably love more than all of them and
sideshow put their spin on them
what sideshow does is they're reimagines
to old and bring it to the forefront
bring it to the new so I'll give you
Thundercats sideshow Premium Format
Thundercats lion-o is within a stop than
lying it off I I remember the music the
music was outstanding they got you
jazzed up got you ready for every
exciting episode and if you grew up in
the 80s and the 90s you knew they'd be
imagine and they came out with another
series I think 2011 and that was pretty
cool the bending King was some fun to
catch raw which was really a disrespect
to the franchise and I was truly upset
when they did that day it was a
deformation of the series it's
disgusting I will not even show that
here all right
then we're gonna go into mama when we
thought about even you thought about his
only objective is the Questor Thunder
catchment as they crash-landed on on
thundera on his planet you understand
and it was really his room so he wanted
their power he wanted to establish
control so he is always held bent on
crushing the Thundercats so far you only
have lion-o and mum Rock I have Cheetara
on pre-order as soon as that comes I'm
over the moon for that I hope they do my
favorite which is Tygra Panthro will get
a little snarf get wilykat wilykat in it
and I hope they do a line of the you
know the bad guys beasts um whatever
what is a beast man not us he man those
guys jackal man or whatever I don't know
I know when I see him but I hopefully to
give you the the battle cat though
though the machine that was driving him
there's a lot of good franchises that's
coming to us from sideshow I'm so
thankful to be part of this community
and the format will change next week
when I bring you something super
exclusive super exciting and 100% mine
every statue you see is mine not all
alone not on borrow my stuff my
collection king of the statues thank you
for tuning in
sorry I was late see you next week
Wednesday when format will change it'll
be one video hope you love it
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]